and a Happy New Year to you welcome to
2023 if you're gonna get this one up on
the second give you a day to really rest
off that hangover
I think I'm projecting I did that for
myself but with the New Year comes a new
list of the top 10 anticipated movies
for that year that would be 2023. as
usual for these anticipated videos no
need for the Pomp and Circumstance to
count down the ten nine eight seven six
we're just gonna go through it also
these aren't in order of anticipation
they're generally speaking in order of
release date and even then not really
but kind of you know what I mean not
gonna take up too much of your time
let's just get into it starting off this
list that's John Wick chapter four John
Wick is an incredible series of action
films which if you look at the director
it's very purposefully done but they
give us that Matrix flavor that the
Matrix resurrections absolutely did not
give us the John Wick Trilogy thus far
is an amazing Trilogy I watch it every
now and then just had a friend come in
to visit from out of town we watched it
just as amazing this time as it was the
last time and the time before that
actually more so I even dressed as John
Wick for Halloween that's your guys's
fault right there I was like okay I get
enough of the comments I guess I'll just
lean into that it was a lot of fun the
costume Crush so I guess thank you for
that yeah point is John Wick chapter
four can't wait to see it next on the
list Scream Six it's Ghostface Takes
Manhattan just like Jason did all those
decades before look it can be argued
that the scream franchise has lasted far
past the expiration date counter
argument though the Scream movies are
far more entertaining than they should
be past the fifth installment it is true
that you can tell Scream 5 had someone
else at the helm where it screams one
through four felt like Wes Craven
because that was the situation but those
Ghost Face killings in Scream 5 were
Savage and if Scream 6 brings me more of
that I'm totally there next up this is
more of a fingers crossed I really hope
this is good kind of Entry that's the
Super Mario Brothers movie look we all
love Mario I'm going into this movie
like most other people where it's like I
I really want to walk out of a Super
Mario Brothers movie going that was one
of the best movies I've seen in a while
yeah you can say what you want about the
voice you know Chris Pratt is Mario how
Wild because he's Mr Star-Lord and he's
gonna sell more tickets but I will admit
I have other motivations for rooting for
this film because if this movie crushes
I will be one step closer to getting
what I've wanted forever which is a
Legend of Zelda movie and a Metroid
movie that's right from doe eyed Optimus
nerd Jeremy all the way to grumpy old
man energy and every year in between
what I have wanted in life Legend of
Zelda movie and Metroid movie and if
this movie sucks if it bombs I'm never
getting that again also want to walk out
of a Mario movie going that was amazing
so there is that next up the first of
two movies I can think of on this list
that were on last year's anticipated and
they got postponed and well now they're
on this year seems a little unfair
absolutely but I do things like that to
keep people from thinking my list is
anywhere around the realm of I don't
know professional Spider-Man across the
spider verse look based on the merits of
the first movie I'm going to look
forward to the sequel I do get a little
worried of the fact that they're really
talking up hey look at all the
Spider-Mans we have in this movie and
I'm just there going but is it a good
character film because that's what I
liked about the last one and for nothing
else a soundtrack should be badass
because again it wasn't the previous
film if you liked into the spider-verse
don't know how you're not looking
forward to Across the spider verse and
the second movie that was on last year's
anticipated list that's now on this
year's anticipated list I figured I
might as well put them back to back
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one the Mission Impossible movies
actually a lot like the John Wick movies
they're films that are amazing action
movies that are not part of a comic book
IP also Tom Cruise is still at it and
he's proven with top gun Maverick that
he's a name and an actor that people
will show up for and granted if the
movie's good but still I'll say since
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol
because I feel like that was the Halo
Spring Mission Impossible back movie
from Ghost Protocol to now in over a
decade these Mission Impossible movies
have not let me down next on the list I
just need to say this one thing and
that's it yeah Christopher Nolan is
making a biopic about Oppenheimer
starring Killian Murphy done I can move
on from there but I guess I'll elaborate
a little more Christopher no is one of
those directors when he's coming out
with a movie that year I will put it on
my anticipated he also filmed it in
black and white you just see the guy's
love for Cinema in his production that
recording of Oppenheimer talking about
him recalling when the bomb went off you
know I am become death destroyer of
worlds yes that sound bite was played in
the Linkin Park album A Thousand Suns I
want to see the story of the life of the
person who became that man next up
everyone's favorite senior citizen
kicking ass no I'm not talking about Tom
Cruise twice talking about Indiana Jones
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
but Indiana Jones and the kingdom of the
Crystal Skull did suck balls and I'm a
sucker for a comeback story you know
it's like I'm rooting for this movie
like people in the movie Iron Will were
rooting for will like we root for Rudy
we're all in the stadium instead of Rudy
Rudy it's Indy Indy you know like we
want Indiana Jones to be good and I just
can't look past the fact that James
mangold's the one in the director's
chair he's been kicking ass lately plus
you got mads Mickelson as the film and
on paper there are things that work but
again you do that SQL after 30 years
kind of thing it's either top gun
Maverick or it's Jurassic world Dominion
or Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
I hope this is good please don't suck
next in doing my due diligence and
looking into the movies that are coming
out this year that I might not have
heard about yes I researched a bit but
in looking into the movies of 2023 did
you know that Michael Mann is coming out
with a biopic about Enzo Ferrari in
which Adam Driver is playing the
Assassin himself yeah I didn't until now
and now I know and now I'm like well
that has to be on here look Michael Mann
for me has made hit and miss throughout
his career absolutely but when it's a
hit it's a [ __ ] hit I'm hoping those
years aren't behind him because just in
concept this sounds amazing suppose
that's the fun of doing an anticipated
video because you don't know you don't
really know what you're talking about
and you're allowed to absolutely have
that be the case it's no doubt an
interesting story to be told but if it's
good
next up killers of the flower Moon
what's that you ask well I am glad you
asked it's a film coming out based off
of a book which is the telling of a true
story which is an interesting way of
saying it's Martin scorsese's next film
starring Leonardo Dicaprio and Robert De
Niro also Brendan Fraser did I pronounce
it right look I'm not gonna posture I
don't know much about the story other
than what I read in looking into the
movie for the sake of this video but I
do come from a Time an era a mindset you
can call this grumpy old man energy if
you want but I come from the place where
Martin Score says he coming out with a
new film was an event and it still is to
me the talent behind the camera and in
front of the camera alone no way this
wasn't going to be on the list I hear
that Apple TV plus has this one I've
actually seen that a lot in a lot of the
movies I was looking into this year it's
like 2023s Apple TV's big move to be
like come to our streaming service point
is after all these years I might
actually have to bite the bullet now and
get Apple TV in order to watch this well
this doesn't get delayed till 2024 or
some [ __ ] it's like the last couple
years have made me paranoid that half of
these are gonna be and we're at number
10 the last on this list that would be
Dune part two or Dune chapter two or
Dune two whatever they're going to call
it point is when I heard denieville news
was doing Dune I was like that is what
we call a perfect marriage and after
watching part one I feel that Faith was
properly placed so I've been waiting for
part two and time has flown it's coming
at the end of the year and now we have
Austin Butler and Christopher Walken
joining the cast look I'm going to say
this only because I believe it's true
Dune is the best on-screen Warhammer
we've ever gotten and yeah I can't wait
for chapter two chapter three however
long he keeps doing them and that's it
that's my list some I'm excited for some
I'm curious about others I'm crossing my
fingers hoping they're good but in any
case that's my list my 10 anticipated
films of 2023. thanks again for joining
me at the beginning of another year I'll
try not to bore you as the year goes on
but I'm only part of the conversation
your 10 anticipated movies of 2023 or
five or one however many whatever they
are whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]